Using the Python debugger in a notebook. In
this video, we'll learn how to use the Python
debugger in a Jupyter Notebook or a Colab.
For this example, we are running code from
the token classification section, downloading
the Conll dataset , having a look at it
before loading a tokenizer to preprocess it.
Checkout the section of the course
linked below for more information.
Once this is done, we try to batch together some
features of the training dataset by padding them
and returning a tensor, then we get the
following error. We use PyTorch here but
you will get the same error with TensorFlow. As we
have seen in the "How to debug an error?" video,
the error message is at the end and it indicates
we should use padding, which we are actually
trying to do. So this is not useful and we will
need to go a little deeper to debug the problem.
Fortunately, you can use the Python debugger at
any time you get an error in a Jupyter Notebook
by typing %debug in any cell. When executing that
cell, you go to the very bottom of the traceback
where you can type commands and you can type
commands. The first two commands you should
learn are u and d (for up and down), which
allow you to go up in the Traceback or down.
Going up twice, we get to the
point the error was reached.
The third command to learn is p, for print.
It allows you to print any value you want.
For instance here, we can see the value
of return_tensors or batch_outputs
to try to understand what triggered the error.
The batch outputs dictionary is a bit hard to see,
so let's dive into smaller pieces of it. Inside
the debugger you can not only print any variable
but also evaluate any expression, so we can
look independently at the inputs or labels.
Those labels are definitely weird: they are of
various size, which we can actually confirm by
printing the sizes. No wonder the tokenizer
wasn't able to create a tensor with them!
This is because the pad method only
takes care of the tokenizer outptus:
input IDs, attention mask and token type IDs,
so we have to pad the labels ourselves
before trying to create a tensor with them.
Once you are ready to exit the Python debugger,
you can press q for quit. One way to fix the error
is to manually pad all labels to the longest, or
we can use the data collator designed for this.